[Musique]
elle c'est emmanuel macron qui est réélu
président de la république
si le président demeure le même si le
duel du second tour était annoncé si
l'abstention a été quasi record cette
campagne fut sens au président on
entre gare en ukraine crise sanitaire et
fatigue du politique la france s'en sort
plus fracturées que jamais
[Applaudissements]
récit d'une drôle de campagne à travers
le combat de quatre députés ultra
impliqués
marie-christine verdier jouclas
elle va se démener pour faire réélire
son président aujourd'hui
en tant que vous dites n'est pas seul
camion abad
président du groupe nr à l'assemblée
nationale il va assister au naufrage de
sa candidate et blanche de cash flow qui
ne serait pas été mieux elle cote après
moi j'étais dubertrand concert mathilde
de panneaux
députés ont soumises des quartiers
populaires ancienne militante
associative elle ya cru jusqu'au bout
nous sommes une force populaire
imparable dans le pays
sébastien chenu porte parole de la
candidate marine le pen député du nord
qui va devrait pour briser le plafond de
verre de la candidate d'extrême droite
marchés n'ont pas peur
voyage en france sur les routes d'une
campagne qui ouvre la voie à une totale
recomposition politique
[Musique]
à trois jours du premier tour règne une
atmosphère de désolation chez les
républicains
le dernier meeting de valérie pécresse
a des allures de tournée d'adieux
pire tout le monde craint pour l'avenir
du parti
les personnalités à l'air vont elles
appelées à voter emmanuel macron et au
front républicain hal annonce des
résultats du premier tour tels et déjà
la question
discussions entre damien abad et un
membre d alerte et de l erp et voir
mais ni front républicain dans dimanche
soir j'attends que mon respect pour tous
les lecteurs je me donnerai aucune envie
[Musique]
il
dernier discours de la candidate et
petit message personnel dans une
campagne
annonciatrice d'un cataclysme
je voudrais dire à damien abad à damien
abad qu'il a été un formidable président
de groupe à l'assemblée nationale cette
campagne qui devait être celle des
débauchages n'a pas eu lieu et la
gamelle macro nien est resté assez
europe
reste à savoir combien de temps cette
gamme un maquereau nien restera vide
du côté des insoumis mathilde de canaux
pense que le deuxième tour est à portée
de main un jour à l'élection
présidentielle le 10 avril jean luc
mélenchon va tourner tout dépendra de la
participation des quartiers populaires
des jeunes vis des potentiels
abstentionnistes une cible pour la
présidente du groupe elle est fière
assemblée et vous avez celui du métier
se sont enfin meeting à ivry voilà si
vous avez le temps vous êtes bienvenu
pour qui vous allez voter monsieur moi
oui je vois que pour mélenchon et a
conduit sinon ils nous proposent que la
droite ait toujours voté ou des fois on
n'y allait pas se venger elle est pas
parce que droite et gauche pour moi
c'est la même chose
à quelques encablures des tractages pour
les candidats de gauche aux oubliettes
dans les sondages il a fait arrêter
votre élan
nous on dit plutôt vote efficace c'est
sûr qu'il ya au premier tour de cette
élection présidentielle un vote efficace
qui permet à la fois d'éliminer
l'extrême droite du premier tour et
d'avoir un autre débat que de nouveau à
mâcon le pen avec les débats rend ce
qu'on connaît sur la question migratoire
sur la question de l'identité la
question de la sécurité bref ce qu'on
nous fait à chaque fois
le soir du premier tour la stratégie du
vote utile s'avérera payante mais pas
suffisante
derniers meetings d'avant première ronde
pour marine le pen
à perpignan ville gérée par le rn
sébastien chenu semble détendu sa
candidate n'a fait que monter dans les
sondages en gommant son appartenance à
l'extrême droite le député prépare déjà
le duel avec emmanuel macron pense que
marine le pen est prête et que les gens
le sentent parce que de l'autre côté
noël macro il a un bilan et que les gens
le ressentent dans un pays qui a été
beaucoup abîmé beaucoup brutalisé et qui
aspire à être unis à être réunies
même ambiance de calme dans la loge de
la candidate
à quelques minutes de son entrée en
scène les français ont pris conscience
qu'on ne peut pas se permettre cinq
années de plus emmanuel macron qu'est ce
qui a changé entre 2017 et aujourd'hui
en 2022 bah tout a changé tout a changé
le pays d'ailleurs lui-même a changé pas
en mieux hélas mais je pense qu'elles
ont un sentiment d'urgence pour les
militants le programme de marine le pen
est perçu comme étant ni de droite ni de
gauche
[Musique]
mais bientôt sébastien chenu va préparer
la deuxième étape de la bataille
à deux jours du premier tour
marie-christine verdi jouclas bat la
campagne quand son candidat est resté
bien en retrait depuis le début
beaucoup
à carmaux terre de gauche patrie de
jaurès elle essaie de convaincre mais la
tentation du vote le bel et bien là
pour moi si remède exposeront au pouvoir
si on sort de la démocratie comme vous
le faites pas confiance aux familles
s'ils ne sont pas capables eux mêmes de
choisir ce qu'ils ont fait en temps à
des candidats qui surf systématiquement
sur les peurs quand on brandit le
drapeau les immigrés ils sont là ils
vous prennent votre travail ils prennent
toutes les aides ils sont en train de
mettre aaa c'est votre pays vous vous
croyez que ça c'est un discours qu'on
peut accepte je pense que les gens assez
capables ils seraient six adultes et
forcément ce qu'ils mangent médailles
j'en suis persuadé et je suis persuadé
avec tout le respect que je vous dois je
suis persuadé que les jeunes il faut
arrêtez arrêtez de les prendre pour dix
hommes femmes il n'y a pas de soucis aux
virades l'image je vous souhaite
beaucoup de nouveautés voilà on s'assied
rsa c'est une vérité pas quoi
à l'issue du premier tour emmanuel
macron arrive en tête avec 1 million 600
mille voix de plus que la candidate du
fn
valérie pécresse est en dessous de la
barre des 5% un fiasco pour les
républicains
jean luc mélenchon se hisse en troisième
position ces 7 millions 700 mille
électeurs vont bientôt être considérés
comme des faiseurs de roi
le soir du premier tour tout le monde
attend les consignes du vote du vétéran
de la présidentielle
mathilde de panneaux et visiblement
bouleversé d'avoir échoué si près du but
et ne fera pas de neige à le voir madame
le pen
il ne faut pas de veine seule voix à
madame le pen
et d'appeler ses électeurs à se
mobiliser pour ce qu'il veut être le
troisième tour les législatives
nous avons devant nous d'autres aux
élections nous tiendrons à chaque étape
notre rang
réfléchissez si
bien que la consigne se veulent claires
l'expression de front républicain ne
suffit plus la fameuse formule du ni-ni
elle aussi n'est plus d'actualité
chez les as l'air on dit peu ou prou la
même chose le lendemain du vote c'est le
branle bas de combat
le patron christian jacob s'est évertué
à expliquer une ligne un peu flou une
île qui a surtout l' avantage de
préserver l'unité du parti
aucune voix ne se portera jamais sur
marine le pen simplement certains
choisiront de voter blanc et d'autres
choisiront un bulletin à bulletin macro
c'est une réalité on va pas la gâcher
damien abad lui se veut plus explicite
on le dit macro compatible n'a pas
changé je les dis hier soir voilà je
voterai emmanuel macron je ne pouvais
pas un signe égal entre entre l'extrême
droite et le candidat républicain et
c'est ce que je vais défendre ce matin
merci non mais on n'est pas là dedans
sur le sujet aujourd'hui c'est déjà
l'élection présidentielle deuxième
taureau ou l'impérieuse nécessité
d'éviter l'explosion du parti à quelques
semaines des législatives
[Musique]
du côté du rn les résultats du premier
tour sont plein de promesses
sébastien chenu dès le lundi matin
enchaîne les plateaux télé avec une
analyse des reports de voix qui
augurerait d'une victoire de sa
candidate
pour la première fois on a des réserves
pour la première fois cette année un
conte qui doit aller en chercher
et 4 points quand même entre les deux on
avait six mois dans les pattes et on est
bon mais là ce niveau là donc oui en
ayant des puits sont confiants que
pierre aucun des lecteurs de jean luc
mélenchon de fabien roussel voir m des
ninjas d'eau qui est prêt à sauver la
tête des modèles macron en se disant je
vais relire un président de la brutalité
le président des gilets jaunes à qui les
a et bornier le président de la retraite
à 65 ans et il va dérouler son discours
il va répéter à l'envi que le président
de la république ne peut pas se
métamorphoser subitement au candidat de
gauche qu'il a appauvri les plus pauvres
en somme faire des manuels macron
l'homme du passif en
[Musique]
vous
ont fermé des lits d'hôpitaux on vous
avait laissé des retraités avec 8 euros
par jour pour subsister on vous a vu ne
pas ré indexer les retraites deuxième
objectif préparer le débat et faire
oublier aux français l'image déplorable
d'une marine le pen qui perd pied face à
emmanuel macron en 2017
on va voir comment s'organisera
des sparring partner
partenaire de débat on verra j'ai quoi
comment le fait est là pendant je pense
que c'est le fonds le fonds le fonds
vous aviez joué emmanuel macron en 2017
assaël
et jouer
dans l'édition
avant le débat la candidate du r n
oubliera pas cette fois ci de se mettre
au vert pour être reposé le jour j
se mettre au vert une obligation pour la
députée macro nist testée positive au co
vide marie-christine vers dijon classe
doit s'isoler et interrompre sa campagne
certaines q quand elle pourra sortir
elle parviendra à convertir des
électeurs mélenchonistes de voter macron
ici dans son fief à rabat 16 dans la
commune où j'habite mélenchon a fait
plus de 33% devoir donc c'était pareil
en 2017 mais pas avec un écart aussi
important les 33 % il ya dedans des gens
à qui effectivement on pourra aller
s'adresser et leur prouver que notre
projet est un projet social est aussi un
projet de gauche le jour même emmanuel
macron va au contact cibler les classes
populaires ils visitent denain dans le
nord et très vite on largue
regardez combien par mois alors que le
niveau mon mari ouvrier à 8h en semaine
à temps des jeux vidéos ci est donc ça
devient compliqué
visite un terrain qu'ils tranchent avec
la première partie de la campagne
sur le terrain justement la bataille se
durcit pour marine le pen ce jour là
dans le vaucluse jojo un département où
elle est arrivée largement en tête au
premier tour
tout entre vite des manifestations la
renvoie à ses racines d'extrême droite
dix habitants conteste un point de son
programme l'interdiction du voile dans
tout l'espace public
un uniforme
je cherche à imposer au fur et à mesure
du temps des gens qui ont une vision
radicale de banane c'est qu'on a
vraiment c'est pas vraiment d'accord
avec vous
le parti veut donc témoigner de sa
puissance à travers les meetings dont le
soir même à avignon alors sébastien
chenu retrouve ses partisans
quatre mille personnes venues acclamer
leur combattante
c'est la mobilisation était connu ses
premiers meetings pas de tour sa
première grande prise de parole de
marine le pen donc donné ce qu'on peut
être intéressant
petit aparté avec caroline parmentier
la toute-puissante conseillère presse de
marine le pen une pièce maîtresse de la
campagne à l'est boston
5 à 10 minutes à peu près sûr vu pour la
voix du nord j'ai vu pour la voix du
nord il le seul problème ce que je ne
sais pas
ce soir là c'est un peu la fête avec
d'autres élus comme emmanuel péri le
député du pas-de-calais
vraiment intéressant
il ferme au tibet l'apprend la campagne
alors que cheikh sébastien chenu est
devenu populaire de perpignan ça va
le pire
je n'aime pas ne pas le bien bravo
chaleureux et volubile
il sait y faire
un petit mot pour chacun mais pas photo
et en sourires pour tous
moi je le veux bien parce qu'il a une
prestance il faudra parler avec
l'arrivée il est proche du peuple
[Musique]
comme à chaque fois marine le pen va
insister sur le déguerpissement
personnes modestes personnes des classes
moyennes même des classes aisées qui
subissent et ce pouvoir centré autour
d'un homme un homme seul
[Applaudissements]
bain de foule pour marine le pen
on veut la touche et la photographier
lui parler
ironie de l'histoire quelques instants
plus tard certains militants rentrer
chez eux angus macro
[Musique]
le président justement il cherche lui à
rosir son discours pour attirer les
électeurs de gauche mais aussi à lever
redire marie-christine verdier jouclas
défend bec et ongles le bilan écolo de
la majorité selon elle l'arrêt des
centrales à charbon ou du plastique à
usage unique était une preuve
d'engagement pour la planète et le
discours de marseille ne serait que la
suite logique
ce 13 avril à le candidat macron passe
au vert font si
[Musique]
la politique que je mènerai dans les
cinq ans à venir sera donc écologie on
ne sera pas mon prochain premier
ministre
sera directement chargé de la
planification écologique
le fait qu'on dise qu'on veut aller
beaucoup plus loin sur des enjeux
importants que l'écologie fait partie de
ces enjeux importants mais pourquoi on
dirait que c'est un sincère c'est
répondre à une attente c'est écouter
aussi et c'est pas juste draguer les
électeurs de jean luc mélenchon et
yannick jadot c'est leur apporter l'idée
clair qu'on veut aller dans le même sens
de toute façon et que d'un autre
programme il y avait déjà le goji ce
soir là c'est le débat un moment qu'elle
va partager comme il ya cinq ans avec
des militants en marche dans la même
salle qu'en 2010 est d'ailleurs au début
de son engagement politique
très vite tout est fin prêt
et la députée devient plus que jamais
aux supporters
il faut dire que ce jour là le candidat
macron a enfilé les gants de boxe pour
le plus grand plaisir de la députée vous
ne parlez pas à d'autres dirigeants aux
panneaux de banque
sexy effet que le propos ni qu'on ne
pouvait pas défendre correctement sur ce
sujet des intérêts de la france parce
que vos intérêts sont liés à des gens
proches découvre qu'il faut aider les
très petites entreprises en leur
accordant des baisses de fichier n'était
pas aux grands groupes mais j'ai ma peau
comme vous l'avez c'est ce qu'elle a
fait passer lorsque vous parlez de
baisses d'impôts une pensée toujours aux
français seront prioritairement
bénéficié avec l'archet le jean se
chante et les chefs d'entreprises
pourront donner une priorité aux
français dans les embauches cinéma de
gauche le pen de la mexicaine est de
dire vrai je compatis réel
des réactions relayé par son armée de
toute hausse
c'est une façon d'appuyer là où ça fait
un peu mal c'est à dire de montrer
excusez moi mais l'incompétence de la
candidate marine le pen
surcoût est reine on n'aura pas les
mêmes éléments de langage
le lendemain sébastien chenu recommence
sa tournée des plateaux télé pour
commenter le débat sur le terrain c'est
son acolyte député emmanuel blé riz qui
relaie cette parole
après m
super
ultra que la présidentielle marine le
pen oui j'ai vu le débat hier oui mais
il était 13h alors vous voyez il lui a
coupé la parole et une fois c'est pas
honnête on est vraiment j'ai croisé des
dizaines de personnes sur le marché tout
le monde sort ce qui se profile 1 2
c'est du mépris ça c'est le même esprit
mais en fait s'il a agi là pendant trois
heures comme il a jugé que le peuple
français pendant cinq ans
ici 39 % des électeurs vont voter marine
le pen au premier tour 15% seulement
emmanuel macron alors il croise des
habitants ou langage plus extrême que
celui d'ordinaire usité devant les
caméras il a du mal à assumer pour qu il
vaut tout retombe pourquoi pas pour ma
part j'aurais pensé
mort vu s'énerver quand même bon ce
mobilisme d'accord t'as dans peu de
temps
disons que l'os est le prénom le prénom
sont pas non mais bien compris ce que
j'ai voulu dire le prénom sont pas son
premier rôle important s'ils vivent sous
le même drapeau tous ensemble voilà cent
ans et vivraient côte-à-côte plutôt que
face à face le débat a aussi laissé des
traces monsieur à trac pour la
présidentielle marine le pen légèrement
venant à vous comporter avec les a
écoutés maquillage à ça et en plus vous
a pas de complot monsieur me comble au
salon qui accueille
piscines en france n est pas les prêtres
à 15 kilomètres de là se tient le
dernier meeting de marine le pen
[Musique]
à l'intérieur comme à son habitude
sébastien chenu se prête au jeu des
salles filles
le matin à kelowna exactement à 49 ans
sébastien chenu c'est coloré en bleu
marine il ya huit ans seulement avant il
a été chef adjoint de cabinet de
christine lagarde en 2005
puis et conseiller en communication
auprès des ministres durant quatre ans
sous nicolas sarkozy
[Musique]
est ce que vous voyez demain si marine
encore trop de ballons sera exactement
ce qu'elle veut de moi elle sait que je
suis à ses côtés pour servir notre pays
nos idées elle même
quand certains ont rejoint les sirènes
et maurienne sébastien chenu a su rester
fidèle où ledit ministrable
est ce que vous le verriez c'est marine
le pen
je suis pas facile de dire mais
mais quelques jours plus tard toutes ces
prospectifs se révéleront
obsolète
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à deux jours de l'échéance emmanuel
l'agro choisi l'occitanie pour son
dernier déplacement de campagne
à regard de cordes
j'adore dans la région de la députée
verdier jouclas à deux heures et demie
de voiture tout de même bien en
occitanie viennent à la ruralité schéma
collègues huguette genia qui a fait un
super boulot pendant cinq ans et donc je
suis très très contente que ça se passe
à la ba
figeac est une petite ville industrielle
et socialistes en pleine campagne qui a
placé jean luc mélenchon en deuxième
position derrière emmanuel macron
dans la foule d'autres parlementaires du
coin
comme mireille robert delaunay
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
et par contre moi je suis équipé je suis
suivie dans tout ce qu'on dit
est la grande question du jour est la
suivante franchement je ne sais pas on
va pas pouvoir le voir d'approcher la
vache ça va être compliqué
la députée va même avoir quelques
surprises
révélatrice de l'époque arnaud viala
président du conseil général de
l'aveyron étiqueter les républicains est
là aussi
alors je veux dire oui à l'eau depuis la
7e
je vous
[Musique]
non mais bon
le premier ministre en fin de cdd a
aussi fait le déplacement
dans le petit centre ville de figeac on
les place mérite pour écouter celui qui
va être réélu président de la république
bientôt les longues minutes d'attentes
sont enfin récompensés pour
marie-christine verdier jouclas
mais les rennais
mais ce jour-là à figeac des militants
anti libéraux et écologistes ne
l'entendent pas de cette façon
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
deux jours plus tard
emmanuel macron été réélu avec 58,6 %
des voix
38,5 % des inscrits cinq points de moins
qu'en 2017
[Applaudissements]
la présidence la
présidente